I've been kicked in the balls quite
often this is worse we've got our three
best friends today to get a full day of
beauty and grooming experience I let no
one in my life work we like to be a
grown-ass man with smooth as hounds they
are kind of freaking out and they're
pretending like they're all macho
inherently don't you think we might have
a better pain tolerance oh I just know
that like my face is gonna become nicer
big break oh boy
nobody told me about the hot stuff ha ha
ha man ah that didn't come off smooth
well man I need you to be gentle with me
like I'm being slated for dinner or
something like feathers are being
plucked out the kind lady who's doing
this for me
it looks very kind but is straight-up
Savage after this like I know like pain
pain is just something else now to all
the people who said Shannon your legs
aren't that hairy they were I'm
discovering new body parts because I
didn't know that this thing even existed
or had any nerve endings this is
actually been a journey to
self-discovery I'm just worried that it
shouldn't look like I'm too groomed
I feel like someone's feeling of like
thin strips of my skin it's like a small
punch thing I am unable to form thoughts
right now because my thoughts are just
paint paint paint black paint paint
black paint how do women do this every
month week every week I have been broken
like I've been tell ya I can tell you
there's a difference but it's not really
hair is not worth the pain man after the
threading my face has changed color
completely it's calming there is no
sudden pain I feel intensely judged
right now because just mine my nails and
terrible shape man she started doing
this she said are you sure this is the
first time I'm getting a manicure done I
just went told that I have many cuticles
that's that's a good thing right my
nails are practically shining they are
literally shining I didn't know nail
shine man
I clipped my toenails once in six months
so yeah I'm sore dude was exclaims now
this is just what I use when I couldn't
find a scale around in my life I've I've
had my shoes polished this feels like
that but ten times better now that I
look down and see like a smoothest leg
you know after you've been through such
turmoil I think such a painful
experience is extremely unifying it was
destructive I feel a lot colder now
because like I just feel like this like
no hair protecting my limbs anymore and
this is like so much wind all of a
sudden I'm leaving happier than I came
in this does make you feel good so I
would not judge somebody if they would
want to go to a spa and I have less hair
than you do but yeah you kind of do but
but I'll get that changed